foreign
[Music]
from Hell comic book hero spawn returns
to the big screen Bloom house boss Jason
Bloom talked in an interview with
comicbook.com about the development of
the new movie and already dared to make
a release date prediction spawn is a
successful comic series that has been
around since the early 90s it is about
the soldier and assassin Al Simmons who
was murdered and negotiates a deal with
a ruler of hell to come back to earth
from then on he pursues his revenge as a
hellspawn and fights criminals as well
as creatures from Hell the comic book
series was already made into a film back
in 1997 and although it was a financial
success it was not particularly well
received by critics and fans according
to producer Jason Bloom the reboot is
currently being worked upon very
actively and the aim is for a theatrical
release in 2025 whether this can be
adhered to depends very much on how long
the writer strike in the U.S continues
Todd McFarland the creator of the comic
is to direct the movie for the leading
role Django Unchained actor Jamie Foxx
has been talks for years we will inform
you as soon as further information about
the reboot of Spawn is available
[Music]
foreign